bougival ville des impressionnistes un
circuit en zodiac est proposée par le
nautic parc une base nautique située en
bord de seine pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir les grands noms des
impressionnistes et célia gars tsongo
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes avec nous
alors c'est une balade de deux heures
qui aura lieu ces deux prochains
week-ends oui samedi 5 et dimanche 13
juin prochain vous pourrez embarquer à
bord d'un zodiac un bateau pneumatique
qui vous permettra de découvrir le
berceau des impressionnistes sur l'île
de la chaussée onéreux noirs qui étaient
présents et puis une fois n'est pas
coutume on met à l'honneur
berthe morisot qui a non seulement vécu
à bougival mais fait également
énormément de tableau et a été un peu le
le le le coordinateur une sorte de chef
de file de tous ce nouveau courant et
donc concrètement comment ça se passe
alors c'est une visite commentée sur la
scène avec le state escale de bougival h
à tous la particularité les visiteurs
s'installent dans des bateaux de 6
places l'ensemble forme une petite
flotte qui se regroupent au près dans
droit au singulier accompagné d'un guide
droit frappant bien évidemment la
grenouillère qui a été l'endroit magique
pour les animations en ile-de-france et
monet renoir ont passé énormément de
temps là bas est très souvent ils
étaient ensemble ils décident l ensemble
du même tableau
et au moment de nos visites quand on
descend et qu'on fait escale à la
grenouillère par exemple on montre les
deux tableaux dans la côté de l'autre
vous pourrez aussi le découvrir le pont
de bougival et ses écluses des
explications sur l'origine et le
fonctionnement de celles-ci seront
proposées au cours de ce circuit vous
apercevrez également les vestiges de la
machine de miles la machine de marly qui
était une des grosses roues à aubes qui
vont pouvoir avec le mouvement de l'eau
entraîner l'ol à faire remonter jusqu'au
château de versailles
aujourd'hui on n'a bien évidemment que
des vestiges et des aspects mais c'est
un endroit assez magie et donc à qui
sont destinés ces balades en zodiacs et
bien alors c'est pour tout public un
même si les ans
en seront peut-être moins intéressés par
des explications du guide
en tout cas c'est la septième année que
les circuits des impressionnistes existe
et c'est souvent complet il faut donc
penser à réserver sur le site ww point
activité qui raynaud tic point fr il
reste encore des places disponibles
merci célia gars tsongo d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
journaliste pour tv 78